my last memory is June 25th  2154  I was happy  10 must enter the challenge the goal is  the conquest of freedom after they  consider measures oh this is an John  your quest for the contenders now things  get interesting Adam runs the quest this  is all game escape when you leave don't  in you die welcome back my friends to  the show that never ends  contenders are engaged the puzzle  established various elements are being  linked up  now let's see if they can figure out how  to put them all together  run  ah  if you fail there won't be dire  consequences  we'll start a revolution they're off the  grid  get them back on the grid  you know I don't like secrets don't make  me hurt you more than necessary  you